hi I'm Maria I'm a tasty producer today
my coworker and friend Betsy challenged
me to make three-course meals for two
people with limited budget our budget of
whatever is in this piggy bank
but you will also have access to a few
freebies in the pantry good luck thank
you my budget is fifteen dollars first
cause I'm going to use shallow and I'm
going to use half shallow for my first
course and I'm going to use the other
half for my main dish I just sharpen my
lady so it's very sharp and you kind of
want to slice like very same and I'm
going to soak shallow in the water so
it's kind of removed suffice like on
unique flavor
so moving on to the next step I think
this is one of the exciting things I'm
making ricotta cheese the two cups of
milk here is over medium heat for five
to eight minutes add in two tablespoons
of white vinegar and one teaspoon of
salt
when I give a gentle stir so while my
ricotta is sitting over there I'm going
to cut my produce
I picked tomato and peach so I like
using seasonal ingredients because it's
cheaper and it's like taste much better
okay so I drain my shallow I wanna just
pat dry clues nobody likes watery salad
okay and I'm going to make little dress
one and a half tablespoon of olive oil
1/2 tablespoon vinegar 1/2 teaspoon of
salt streets all over
I like tossing salad of its using my
hand goes hand your hand it's the best
tool so this is pretty much done I'm
gonna just keep in the refrigerator and
I'm going to finish my recorder next
it's separated I'm going to strain this
for 15 to 20 minutes I'm going to just
put it in a refrigerator so it will
separate from car to way and I'm going
to discard away by the way by the way
where is this watery part it's like look
at the part and a card it's the cheese
part right the first thing I want to do
is trip clumps what you want to do is
scrub those clumps because it's usually
coming dirty and now I'm going to soak
them with salt water so I'm going to
keep them in a refrigerator I change
water for my clump it's a fresh water
right now another protein it strips
people think it's a little expensive but
if you only buy
six sweet it's not expensive and when
you are buying shrimp I recommended to
buy shell insurance so it's cheaper than
buying peeled and deveined shrimp
because they are the cost of labor fee
so my labor it should be to devein you
want to cut the back part so
so girls think this is good for two
right yes I'm going to start boning
pasta next I'm going to cook my shrimp I
have 2 tbsp olive oil and butter I'm
going to shrink cooks super quick and if
you cook too long they will become like
rubbery texture so you just want to put
a minute and I'm going to add the
shallots
anabolic
in Kota teaspoon of chili pepper and
once shallow it's translucent and have a
nice good fragrance you're going to add
a half cup of white wine when you are
cooking with alcohol you don't
necessarily need to use expensive one
because we are cooking anyway it's
lovely its opening already just remove
this once so I don't overcook it now I'm
going to add my pasta my main dish it's
almost done always tastier food so first
step I'm going to heating up one cup of
heavy cream
vanilla extract
and while it's going I'm going to mix
sugar and three egg yolks I decided to
make this dish because X sugar are
freely so I called boiling water my
heavy cream mixture is cool to touch
alright so it is well mixed and I'm
going to put them in ramekins the reason
I'm putting on the class when you are
cooking rummaging will move around while
baking or I'm moving the dish pour hot
water right going to the other
cranberries it's baked I want to have a
jiggle in a center I'm going to chill
this two babies in a refrigerator for at
least two hours so it will set
ricotta cheese look you kind of want to
drop some ricotta here there we're gonna
top with some sniffing our basil and
when you play pasta you kind of want to
do a little bit high not flat so finer
you know twist the tongue sweet shrimps
each I'm going to top with basil kind of
want to make it even so if you don't
have blowtorch this is the easiest way
to caramelize the sugar on the top so
I'm just heating up with this open flame
so please be careful when you're doing a
home oh my god ah good brain yes oh my
sweet horses are ready to serve I'm
going to bring my friend Cooney and
Ramon I hope they think this meal aids
more than $50 first cause it's tomato
and peach and homemade ricotta salad
cheers Cheers
I'm into dance
I think I dish like this would be like
12 15 dollars I don't know it's what
tomatoes and fruit yeah but like at a
hipster restaurant where it's like oh
yeah okay if you go to Hollywood yes
somebody's got to pay for all the mason
jar light bulbs you know yeah now your
noodle overboard
it's no good okay I definitely associate
like a seafood pasta dish like this with
some big bucks like this is why I don't
make it at home this is like a $20 dish
of the restaurant for sure oh yeah
easily
you're a great choice
yes so how much do you guys think the
three proceeds for two people cost me I
would say like 45 maybe if you got stuff
on sale and you run it to the at least
60 I just use $15 no no way
wha-wha can we go grocery shopping
you're like the grocery food master
thank you I have one more surprise for
you
it's not a puppy haha I made cocktails
winter peas are useful salad and the
leftover wine and soda
so now you guys know what's possible
weeds only $15 cheers to that
[Laughter]
[Music]